what does it mean to break a story
so breaking a story is how you figure
out what all the actual scenes are in an
episode
whether it's your own pilot you're
writing at home or whether it's an
episode of a show that you're working on
and there are different methodologies
about how to do it
i can tell you my favorite methodology
of doing it which is
i
and this is a combination of ways i've
seen it done in multiple rooms that like
now this is the system that i like so
first of all i think it's just a
question of
what
did we think our main characters would
be doing in this episode right and if
you're doing a pilot it's like what is
the story i want to tell about my main
characters
and you can on note cards or on a
whiteboard lit as simply as you know i
need nicole to figure this out i need um
you know adam to go here i need um you
know we need
conflict between the mother and daughter
to get us to the place we need to be in
the next episode big ideas like that
they don't have to be super specific
it's just like you know here are things
we think our characters need to do
and
especially if you're working on staff
right you're in a writer's room
the next part of that is do we owe
anything from the last episode was there
stuff that we thought we were going to
include in that script that we didn't
do we still need it does it go here so
you have that conversation and then you
look at the episode coming up and like
have we set up everything we need to for
that or do we owe something in this
episode to make sure that we get to
episode six you know clean and nobody's
like what where'd that come from
so to me those are all the starting
conversations
and once you do that you kind of have a
loose shape of the episode right you you
have
say
five things you know that your leading
man has to
to deal with like five scenes with your
leading man
three scenes that are about his
relationship with his leading lady maybe
two scenes of the leading ladies story
on her own
and then oh we have to set up this plot
point that's going to pay off in episode
6.
oh we want to do a b story about this
set of secondary characters
and you're just talking it through what
is it
once you have that
you can start to really talk about
what's happening in those actual scenes
so it's like okay in the scene where
nicole's going to get the document and
she's going to be super pissed off about
it like what is she doing where do we
find her you know is she in her morning
routine is she on the phone like you're
really talking that through because if
she's on the phone maybe she's saying
something that's going to set up one of
those b stories we need later right you
can see if you can make connective
tissue
between that scene and a scene that
needs to happen later
and then what does that paperwork mean
why is she so angry about it is she
screaming at someone is she throwing a
fit in the room by herself like what is
it so you really sort of nail down
what's happening in that scene and you
do that for every one of those moments
that you've already talked about
and then once you have them all fleshed
out and how many scenes are in an
episode will vary between what show
you're on i would say
it has been my experience that if you
have more than 35 scenes your script's
probably going to be too long because
you want to be able to
write you know the description that the
art department needs to figure out what
they're decorating and you need to you
know if there's a specific costume thing
you need costumes to do you got to
describe it and that kind of stuff so
you need some room to play
with those descriptions or with a long
exchange of dialogue
and so say now you have your 35 scenes
well now you got to figure out what
order they go
so that's the next stage of the break is
to say okay well i think that one we
have here is the perfect act out for act
two so you move it to the bottom of act
two
and then it's like okay well we know
this is the end of the episode so we're
gonna move this here
and we know this is the first scene that
we wanna do and you just literally start
moving the cards or writing on the board
to put the things in order
and then you end up with an episode of
television and then that doesn't
necessarily mean your work is done right
especially if you're staffed
you're going to pitch stuff along the
way like the day you do that big
overview conversation your showrunner
comes in if they were off doing other
things and you the room will pitch in
the stuff on the board or her
and they'll be like oh i love all that
i'm not so sure about this maybe come up
with some alts for that so you keep you
know doing the work in each process
until you get to that we have 35 scenes
in order that feels like an episode and
then
the writer of the episode or the number
two in the room will pitch through the
whole episode for the showrunner and the
showrunner will sometimes just love it
and like great go write an outline and
sometimes the showrunner is making
adjustments as you're pitching and being
like no no i love that can you do me a
favor though and make sure
um we don't do x because actor a has a
problem with that so just find an alt
for that end of the the scene great make
yourself a note keep pitching
and you'll take all that information
with you and then go write the outline
so it's really the building blocks
breaking a story is coming up with the
building blocks of the episode
when you're breaking a tv show story
what are the first few things you're
trying to figure out
if it's
if it's for a thing that you're writing
yourself right i mean you have the idea
of what you think the show is so
where it starts i think is always like
an important thing to nail down where
what moment is the first moment of this
show for you
um what is the way you want to introduce
your main character or characters what's
the
the way that you want the audience to
interpret
them based on their movement where they
live where how they dress whatever the
key elements are to you
so i think figuring those things out
right away is really important
and
i i would say in pilot writing if you
i always know how my pilot ends in terms
of the broad sense of i know the ending
is going to be
that we're going to realize that
character a is actually the one who
committed the murder and nobody else
knows it
right that's going to be the reveal at
the end of the pilot so everything i'm
writing is writing towards that and
that'll help you sort of know like oh i
don't have enough twists or turns or
that kind of thing so i feel like
knowing how you start
knowing how you want to introduce your
characters
and knowing where the pilot is ending
to me are the most important things when
you're trying to then go break the story
when you're breaking it in a room with
other writers i think
you know having tent poles of the
episode are what what we refer to it as
of like
you know you cannot necessarily know how
the episode's supposed to end other than
i know we're supposed to get to the
point where he admits he loves her at
the end of the episode i'm not quite
sure how to get there but i know that's
how we're ending
and i i know at the midpoint we need to
have something go wrong where
everybody's at each other's throats and
they're going to have to recover from
that for the rest of the episode
and then my idea for how to start the
episode is x and then your team can help
you fill in all the other stuff in
between that's the joy of having a
writer's room is you don't need to have
all the answers like you do when you're
writing your pilot you can say here's
what i have and then everybody else
joins together to help you fill in the
parts that you don't have and you don't
have to take every idea that comes
unless it's from your showrunner and
then you kind of do
but
if someone pitches something that you
don't love it's okay to be like
can we try and beat that like i'm not
sure i like i really want to go down
that road and if your showrunner likes
it and may make you do it but it's fine
to be like can we come up with some alts
for that and then you pitch the version
you like best to your showrunner
and sometimes they're like oh i love
that and that conversation's over and
sometimes they're like not sure about
that act out fact three though and then
you can be like well we had some other
ideas in the room and you can pitch the
thing you didn't love
but that
someone in the room pitched and maybe
the showrunner's going to be like yes do
that okay because it's not your show so
you do it
when it's your pilot you get to make all
the choices until you're doing it for a
studio or a network and then they can
say to you i don't like the act out
factor
or i don't do notes yes
but that sounds like that's what the
beauty of the of the cards is or doing
it with a board is it's movable parts
and so you can show them if you say okay
we can try it even though maybe in your
mind you're like this is never going to
work but we'll we'll go with it we'll
try it so you move it here and then you
show okay if i move that then i have to
move this here and then it's kind of
there for you to see yes and that's the
best part of it is like you try it and
then everyone can see like oh wait that
means that like now all the action's
shifted to the middle of the episode and
we don't have anything up here so how do
we fix that and it's maybe it's moving
back the thing that you just moved and
we find a different solution for here so
it allows you to see it and then have
the conversation
and i think you know the story that i
love about why i'm still a note card
girl like i have um boards like in my
house that i just pull out and like
stick note cards to them and i have one
up on the wall
and um part of the reason that i am a
note card girl is because of the
legendary story of um stephen bachcho
and the hill street blues pilot which
when they first screened it was kind of
a disaster
and he was like give me a chance to fix
it and he went back to his office and he
laid the entire episode and note cards
out on the floor
and he reassembled the pilot moving the
cards around and pulling cards out
and then that became the pilot that
changed television so being able to put
all the cards out and be like
okay there's just too much in act two
that's the problem because now that all
the cards are lined up i can just tell
act two is too long so what do i do or
you know
just saying like nope i need this to
happen sooner and moving the physical
card
now on a board you can do that because
you're crossing stuff out or you know
whatever but it's to me it's easier with
cards there's also now the electronic
software
that we've all had to use during zoom
rooms like writer's room pro or mirror
and you know for people who prefer to do
it that way and i think final draft even
has a board function now and so
even for yourself you can use those
programs if you want to because you
don't want to actually write on physical
note cards or you don't have room to
have a whiteboard you can use those
programs to do the same thing
just as a side note do you know did they
have to shoot new scenes for hill street
blues or did they
just do it in post i believe it was just
a recut i feel like i i read boccico's
book and i feel like it was just a recut
i could be wrong because i haven't read
the book since 2016.
um
but yeah it was just like it's too long
it's kind of all over the place and so
they went in and they they reassembled
it they reimagined it with those cards